people ask like what's your dream at the
beginning i didn't know and then time
flies and then now yeah building company
is kind of my dream but the dream is not
about having a company
the dream is more realistic once you see
you have great people coming and then
you feel like you guys are fighting
together
the feeling is kind of like wow there
are a bunch of strangers
that group together
and having a similar mentality and then
working really hard
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
talking about e-commerce with andrew
chan the co-founder and chief product
officer of aftership a leading post
purchase and tracking platform for
e-commerce businesses
andrew has more than 10 years of
experience in sas product development
and sales he manages the company's
product managers sales teams and
marketing teams before launching
aftership andrew worked for accenture as
a business analyst
you've seen the world transform pretty
remarkably and through your company
aftership which you've co-founded you
really know you're on the forefront of
e-commerce helping online businesses
automate a lot of the process from sales
to fulfillment to shipping some
phenomenal attraction with more than 250
people uh dozens of millions of dollars
raised from the likes of tiger global
and so some of some of the top vc funds
in the world but what's most interesting
for me besides talking about the amazing
successes you've had is really so sort
of your perception of how did e-commerce
change over the last 10 years we've seen
e-commerce boom you've seen it
crazy boom through kovid and so and
you've been experiencing this as a
leader in the field so andrew thank you
very much for being here with me
yeah thanks for having me as well
tell me a little bit about you know
yourself and and take me back ten years
ago how you know how does aftership
start with what vision
yeah i think we started back in 2020 oh
sorry 2011 kind of like 20 uh 10 years
ago so we started like back at the time
we start with the tracking
um problems that we want to solve and
then we uh me and the other co-founders
met in a startup event called startup
weekend so basically it's a hackathon
within 54 hours so you have to build a
product and then compete and we won the
hong kong competition and then we won
the global competition and then we start
from then we we
have like get noticed by techcrunch and
of course like other enterprises
followed so at the beginning the dream
is kind of very simple it's actually not
about
i mean solving problem yes but it's
actually survival you know as a startup
you want to kind of like make sure the
company survive but what we're trying to
solve at the same time is to help
merchants to track package because many
of them that time is still asking the
customer hey go to the carry website and
then click here click here copy and here
and there and then track the shipments
and in that time the shipment takes over
a week or more or even months
so having a proactive update to the
customers is very important so that's
how it started you know about the
product and then times flies at the
beginning it was hoping to build a you
know something the customer ping
survival of the company but now time
flies we got like actually now we got
over 300 people and this year would be
600 and um yeah so um the dreams get
bigger once you get more people you got
more support more trust from other
people and also the customers base is
bigger so we hope to see if we can build
really the best you know solutions for
you know e-commerce solutions to help
our retailers customers to do better job
to succeed yeah
so so we're going back to the beginning
of the last decade and you're betting on
e-commerce and you're looking at
shipping and you're looking at
fulfillment and how to make the customer
experience better obviously today there
is no doubt that the most people in the
world will agree that e-commerce is
eating the world and that that it's it's
much more prominent than in-store
shopping is this is this the same
reality that we had back in 2011 2012 if
you go back to the founding of after
ship was this already a major
understanding by society
yeah i think like e-commerce does
definitely change a lot but it doesn't
really change in terms of like you buy
something you know it's because i mean
as a customer you buy something from a
store and then they ship it out what's
change is kind of like the technology
you of like shopify has grown a lot and
then there's more e-commerce solutions
have been offering like they are i mean
at the beginning it was only mailchimp
but time flies they got more options for
e-commerce merchants and um i think the
uh with the time flying uh the
technology getting better uh there are
some changes and um and at the same time
i think one key thing is amazon amazon
keep pushing everyone's limit at the
beginning you know uh tracking it wasn't
really uh um
everyone's every e-commerce sellers
focus on selling marketing you know
acquisition
it's more on amazon the first guy saying
hey you know what i'm going to give you
better shipping experience you know what
i'm going to give you real-time updates
of the shipments you know like the post
purchase experience on any kind of
experience got pushed because of other
you know key players and also technology
players in the market and definitely
like i see amazon plays for key roles to
change you know shapes what customers
are looking for yeah
right and so if you go back to sort of
how you
how you your position shipping is a
primary
place in
e-commerce what was the main challenge
there why
why did merchants and fulfillment
centers have trouble solving it what's
the challenge with shipping
yeah i think um
shipping is a very complicated problem
is about merchants inventory is about
the shipping cost it's about uh
delivered time and it's about
you know even about the weather it's
about covert so many factors like impact
the shipping experience overall um but
one key thing that we're trying to help
at least like it's like on the tracking
front and also the returns experience
like him can we be better for tracking
yeah definitely the shipping times may
be impacted by let's say covet we see
deliver time got a
stretch you know from few days to even
five days during the the beginning of
the pandemic now it's better but it's
not even
completely uh
become normal
so
having the customers having a full
feasibility of where's the shipments
rather than telling a customer hey go to
this carrier and then just see what's
going on like the merchants should
really take care of the customers keep
them you know engaged coming to a we
call it brand new tracking page to let
the customers to see where is their
shipments exactly
and tell the customer hey this is in
transit or hey telecaster is the
exception
because it's an incorrect address do you
proactively
resolve the problem as a merchant and
also notifying the customer hey it's
okay
and uh at the same time we're trying to
also help on the return experience to
see if we can help the customers to do
the self-service return rather than
asking the merchants i still see many
brands asking customers to fill in
really long form and then email the
merchants and then ask for the shipping
label
no one do that these days you know
people look for amazon quickly clicking
and done kind of do and
yeah i think like uh times flies
merchants uh needs to they have lots of
things on the plate but shipping and um
tracking fulfillment is a tough part to
solve because it's lots of operation
lots of things it's not very obvious
that you can acquire customers it's more
retaining existing customers
people it's kind of like a restaurant
they keep remembering hey new customers
come home come but there's actually lots
of repeating customers that you should
be aware
not you need to retain them make them
advocate et cetera so i think time flies
and then they are more like brands
especially more established brands or
growing brands they definitely look for
how to retaining uh existing customers
and make them more advocates yeah
if you're thinking through the different
pain points of the stores and the
merchants and the e-commerce websites
how big of a role
is shipping or what is the priority that
they would allot to shipping in
comparison to a bunch of other pain
points for example the way their website
looks or or the enrichment of automatic
data on products how big of a priority
is the shipping piece of this i think
the
device merchants like first things
product first thing is the product
itself so if you don't have a good
product you are just like copycat or you
just buy from like you know the drop
shipping kind of like making fast money
and then just like create sales
well that's me i mean that's the things
that you may want to solve first like
finding the right product
market fee and then have the market
needs uh you don't need a lot of people
to resolve that but i think that's the
highest priority as a brand
but afterwards like the website the look
and feel
you know all the marketing techniques
etc i think it's okay it's okay it's
something that basic is enough but you
look at amazon website how beautiful it
is ask ourselves
is it going to be fancy is it what
people looking for uh kind of like
unified experiences kind of like apple
pay kind of like
just simple and then they don't really
worry about too much about the look and
feel of the website uh in the old time
we see lots of you know top brands
really high fashion brands the website's
going fancy it's kind of stuck with
video you know
making you feel like amazing you know a
brand uh
connection but no now he's kind of like
hey go there and then see the product
image blah blah blah so the basic things
i think the brands need to take care but
is it something going to be fancy no
um but shipping is something that many
brands kind of like even not telling the
customers like when the when you shop uh
select product they don't even know when
the product is coming they have to
scroll down to see the shipping you know
policy and then kev guess how when it
delivers and at the checkout it doesn't
reset it and when you after you check
out right we have the full feasibility
notification i think there's kind of
like some basic things it's so weird in
this ecommerce world it's still kind of
um
not uh having that resolved and then uh
i think like brands should really focus
on if they want to really make the
customers happy even new customers you
know it's kind of the first thing they
would see shipping time return policy uh
easy to return or not you know that like
uh uh is the kind of basic it's not the
look and feel anymore look and feel is
really the basic the checkout experience
is like kind of unified this day so how
about the shipping is it better is it
the post purchase experience like
customer support experience those kind
of things i think is really um
especially the cost of acquisition is
getting higher and higher like looking
at the existing customers experience is
really important yeah
and so if we're looking today about you
know looking back at the strategy that
you deployed here you know
specifically you know you're looking at
there's a few different types of people
that you have to cater to right you have
to cater to the merchants who are
selling you have to cater to the um to
the different delivery mechanisms right
you've partnered with more than 900 900
delivery options and then obviously you
have the the you know customer
experience that you have to provide to
the to the buyer
what was sort of the strategy of how
you're creating this
three-sided marketplace how do you know
as a leader of a company to know where
to put your focus and what was sort of
your thinking through that
i think for us like we work with like
over 900 carriers worldwide because we
have like major customers delights from
the us they ship internationally and
then we have uh customers like
in uh uk europe and all over the world
but majority students from the us uh i
think like the carrier strategy in u.s
is like not that hard to choose
especially domestic is only a few key
players so the carrier place when it is
get a little bit more complex when it
goes international
so um i would say uh if you are a brand
scout like domestic it's not something
that hard to figure it out and of course
there is uh we call it uh uh um
more the uh fulfillment fulfillment
solution site
basically the merchants will choose kind
of like if they don't ship with multi
carriers they may have uh they don't
ship by themselves they can actually
find a three people
or warehouse to help you know to do the
shipping logistics and actually we
recommend brands to do it if they is
something that they cannot handle
with those kind of experts you know that
let lesser months to help on that and
for us we more focus on well after you
start out what carrier to choose for us
it's like we would support that but i
think the key thing for us as a solution
provided we eye on the user experience
for
after the clicking button you know the
the the how they receive the
notification is it through sms is if
your em email is it whatsapp or facebook
messengers is it what the customers want
and then proactive notifying customers
and also helping really merchants you
know having a dashboard to find out
what's going on what is my on-time rates
we have the top brands to find out the
on-time delivery rates what what it
means is you promise customers three
days to be delivered let's say on friday
do you know how many like is it really
delivered on friday no brands know it to
be honest like they just oh yeah he got
delivered no one complained so we
actually eyeing more on um on the
software itself and then of the
dashboard and analytics helping the
merchants to find out that shipping
performance and on time rates and then
the shipping reviews like customers are
happy or not delivering on time doesn't
mean customers happy for the shipping
so
to find out that and you off and improve
is more on our products on the tracking
piece that we want to resolve well of
course like this shipping solution just
now mentioned like the the merchants
have to sort out by themselves but with
our solution they can help find you know
oh is it if this solution if this camera
is not on time can we find a better
surface you know that fit our you know
time frame for example yeah
right so essentially you're also
democratizing their ability to to choose
the right you know the right people to
handle the shipping considering
considering the options and especially
in today's competitive world that
becomes ever more important and you
can't just rely on the single provider
that or the single carrier you've agreed
with how does growth
for a company like aftership look like
so you know you reach product market fit
and and then you say okay how do you now
scale this thing what does that even
mean to scale
yeah i think for scaling is a
is a
it's a good problems to to to solve and
we are in the growth stage and then uh i
would say before last year we didn't
really have before a few months ago we
didn't really have a marketing or even a
proper sales team so we are now at the
stage of you know
building ourselves and marketing team uh
worldwide to help you know to reach out
to more merchants definitely to help
more merchants so that's kind of the the
growth thing that we're trying to solve
ourselves but the second thing is for us
is like the product itself has to evolve
so what the reason that we keep still
doing this product after 10 years and
even longer period of time because we
see that the market definitely need uh
software that evolved with time
talk comes out you know technology
changed people's behavior changed but
many software just got stuck
many software they built in the last 10
years for e-commerce is actually
outdated and um they charge an expensive
crazy price but they don't evolve and i
would say merchants are so frustrated
these days like
some solutions selling high price but
not delivering
so we definitely like for us is more on
can we do better can we do really
what the merchants want and evolve with
them together so i would say for us like
the growth pain is like we built we have
more people we got more customers can we
our products you know go also growing at
the same time not stuck there yeah like
some other product yeah
i love it andrew walk me through
you know your personal journey here and
you know what's been most enjoyable for
you
in the last 10 years building this
really cool company
yeah i think
yeah building company you know people
say it's kind of my dream you know
people ask like what's your dream at the
beginning i didn't know and then time
flies and then now yeah building company
is kind of my dream but the dream is not
about having a company
the dream is more realistic once you see
you have great people coming and then
you feel like you guys are fighting
together
the feeling is kind of like wow there
are a bunch of strangers
that group together
and having a similar mentality and then
working really hard for what for
building a software that's so weird you
know like after you know you sit back
and you feel like wow they they they are
we are dreaming the same dream
that is so weird to me and then you feel
so you know i don't know what we have
done right you know we we it's it's just
unrealistic to have great people coming
to help together to build software for
our customers you know they're not
related to be honest you know we are not
related they come you know everyone's
coming 10 hours 12 hours per day 14
hours some people jump in a 3 a.m call i
was like what
that's amazing you know that's how
feeling is unrealistic and keep me you
know keep going on yeah
i love it andrew i really want to thank
you for the time and the energy and it
sounds like such an incredible journey
and it sounds like you know what you've
one of the things that i loved i
mentioned that you're starting with this
you're starting with one specific thing
in mind about it say 10 years ago and
and you're saying how is the company
evolves and is the you know both the
funding get comes in
the customers come in you have so many
more people more than 300 now and going
growing to 600 you have to dream bigger
and you have to think bigger and you
have to come up with with more ideas of
how to remain relevant and i think that
looks back to what you said in the end
about how so many softwares that were
built in the last 10 years they became
non-relevant anymore and and so one of
your roles as a leader of this ship of
aftershift is to maintain the relevance
and to continue growing and obviously
that's exactly what you're doing and it
sounds like an amazing amazing journey
and i really want to thank you for
coming here and sharing it with me so
thank you very much thanks so much for
michael yeah for this opportunity
[Music]
you